sauces crees experts resident in the
house yeah you reviewed the latest sorry
game I did which is a there was a great
line here actually mildly enjoyable mark
of the ninja wanna be that's the line
you chuck that was like that was within
the first ten second having so many
wonderful lines in that review
assassin's creed chronicles china yeah
how was it it's fine it's there it's
it's it's a game that exists you know
it's one of those things it's like i'm
glad i played this i'm not going to
remember that it exists in a week yeah
kind of thing but hey you're glad you
played it yeah I mean it's there at one
thing what I like is that they trade
they did try something new they tried I
mean it is not the first time they did
to d hmm there was a pretty good
actually DS game after Assassin's Creed
22 yeah and that was that game was
actually pretty good and a lot of fun um
this game is more mark of the ninja type
thing it's a stealth game for the most
part you can get into direct combat but
it sucks Rizzo I recommend I mean and it
might be very purposefully sucky to keep
you from from from dealing with it you
know and let except in the worst of
circumstances but this is I mean it
really is very mark of the ninja but
it's a lot less clever and a lot less
sort of kinetic hmm I do a quick little
rundown of what makes market than
integrate that this sort of like
explained that reference a little bit
for mine I think some of it is
locomotion you've got a much greater
sense of energy in how you play mark of
the ninja plus you've got a setting
where it's sort of like it's a whole
screen built like a puzzle yeah whereas
this is a lot more linear you're going
from point A to point B um and as a
result you spent a lot of time waiting
as you often do in a stealth game in
assassin's creed chronicles Johnny you
know i'm spending a lot of time waiting
for the right opportunity either sneak
buyer to assassinate or something like
that but what's interesting is in
something like mark of the ninja um the
the sort of the stealth puzzles the way
you move through the environments they
become a lot more clever they become a
lot
harder to go and there's this you you
dirt you you do you do or more moves and
assassin's creed chronicles china as you
move along but the the challenge only
stays with what you're earning there's
never this moment there's never an arc
yeah so like the way the the area's work
or how challenging it becomes so is it
kind of a cakewalk then that respect
like it's cakewalk as much as you can
just basically use the same kind of
strategies right over and over and over
again and there there's sort of this
lack of cleverness and so what happens
is the the pace is very flat um you have
this thing where you could choose any
given chapter in the game and play it
and it feels like any other chapters
approach to you know like most maybe
most games we're at least you know the
best games where there's very much an
arc where the excitement builds in your
and you're leading to something i said
in the review like you know you're
getting to the end because the story
kind of is telling you you're getting to
the end but it doesn't feel like an end
you know it is but it doesn't feel like
one because there's no build-up there's
no you know everything's sort of random
so the all the basics are there for a
great game but it didn't really put them
together in a meaningful way yeah and it
just kind of feels flat as a result it's
gorgeous yeah this looks very pretty ten
bucks on steam at the moment how long
did it take you to complete it I'd say
it took me about four hours that
includes like all the the restarts and
the you know getting killed and which
happened to me a bit you know I it might
not be I wouldn't necessarily call it
challenging but I would say you'd have
to put some thought into it and it's
because it's kind of has that flat
feeling it's easy to just want to move
ahead just finish and so you can run
into some problems if you if you just
sort of lose patience with it is it only
on PC it's on pc ps4 and Xbox box what
ya guys do really like that watercolor
kind of style that's over the
backgrounds have and move the flags
waving I think that's really grates
really good and you're not even seeing
the best stuff here I mean it ends up
looking a lot like the you know the
Chinese masters had some really great
you know way you know brush strokes that
they used and you see the strokes you
see the smudge
is things that make it look very much
like this is you know this was painted
that's why did I move that you saw
before slide yeah the slide is really my
favorite the best parts of the game are
ironically not stealth they're the
things that you're seeing like you're
running our gate moments yeah and it's
not as good as like the escapes and
something like oral is fantastic but
it's the closest the game ever gets to
sort of that freerunning Assassin's
Creed feel which is sort of a shame you
do have some other things like you leap
off of you know you have leaps of faith
and stuff like do birds go cause when
you do it yeah totally right there's
their days and a great painterly seen
the background behind that that
Portuguese is it like good assassin
Templar stuff going on in here is pretty
much black no really I mean I mean but
that yeah that's the other thing we can
try out it is is that the whole thing
you know considering how sort of story
focused it is there's no real world
building or character building or
anything the the stories all told
essentially and in sort of like
interstitials between between chapters
so like I said Assassin's Creed find
that you are Kevin is there no parts
word like links into other ones is this
character part of the lower it is in the
set I mean she was trained by Ezio ok
for example and you know they've they've
done some stuff with comics and things
like that that I not really paid much
attention to I've always been very game
focused and this is their way I think of
exploring like those side stories but
the links to the things I care about now
i will say i haven't played rogue and i
didn't I haven't yet finished unity ok
um so my links are with with you know
mostly with four and beforehand but
honestly the only the only thing she's
doing there so there's a you know the
the precursors the like the former
civilization you know that there's a
there's an artifact in a box and that's
what she's going after what's in the box
it's an artifact ok um and and that's
really all it boils down to is like she
wants the box there's a lot of talk
about some honest ok it's just like I
want that box no we're keeping the Box
I'm moving the box wow I want the box so
that don't we all that's kind of yeah
Fox chases is it more as talking
the box then legend read the box
remember that when I say of course i
reviewed legendary the bond you and it
brings back some really good podcast
moments that we can't talk about here
because they're pretty gross and yeah
okay I see where those content goes to
fester while we have you here just watch
your general thoughts on the the
Assassin's Creed series where it's out
at the moment obviously we're looking
forward to a little London jaunt last
year was interesting where you haven't
played rogue and unity we gave it a
seven out of ten yeah and we gave roga
six out of ten and you'd think i'd be
interested in row because I love snow in
games so I kind of have a soft spot for
going to you know to Chile places so
maybe at some point i'll get to rogue
especially now that it's on pc but i
mean and this is coming from I've got an
assassin's creed tattoo yeah this is
this is a series that I that I love you
know for a lot of reasons I you know but
I feel like a lot of things that I loved
about it have sort of been pushed aside
and in favor of this Ubisoft formula and
this Ubisoft formula being here's a map
with a lot of little icons on it that
all represent content yeah I put in
quotes content and you go when you chase
the content and there's a story that
puts it all together but some of the
magic is gone like for example one of my
favorite things I know people hate the
desmond story okay yeah i'm not one of
those people but i know that a lot of
people hated the desmond story but we
haters they call them so exactly but one
of the things that I've always kind of
uh enjoyed about assassins creed is the
way that it tries to make things that
are typically gamey things that show up
in games we just ignore because they're
things that games do yeah interface and
health are suspension of disbelief yeah
sort of one thing that I always loved
about assassins creed is the way that it
always made some kind of sense out of
every single game II thing then it's
it's it's story structure you're losing
your health ed synchronous yeah or even
things like you press you know the Y
button or the top the triangle button
that was like stuff up here yeah and
this was one arm and this was the other
arm and a was for running and stuff like
that like all that stuff's been thrown
away yeah like all those things that I
think were were neat i get it you know
he games evolve over time but I feel
like it's now just it's become so
gay me and I and I hate that work is
either video right but but a lot of
stuff just feels come try because okay
now we just do it because this is what
video games do yeah man i love the first
came so much i really died my bald head
Kevin that guy I love see the thing as I
love the first game I got a lot of flack
over loving the first game I am as I am
right there with you I really know it
has its two and brotherhood ass or any
better games but I'd love one for what I
mean I think two is the pinnacle but I
think one was a very important game a
very special game um you know for a lot
of reasons you had stuff like this which
is insane now that I that I look back on
it but I mean I spent so much time in
that world just looking for stupid flags
and eventually all that stuff it's just
like oh you there are ways to just
uncover every freaking icon on them yap
but but I mean all right so if you're
talking about stuff that has now become
Gainey within the series is this really
it's is it a criticism of the series has
changed or just that we've done it so
many times within assassin's creed that
it now just feel like the formula is
born and so we feel familiar with it and
so the stuff that like you know the
magic and wonder of exploring Jerusalem
you know in the first one you're not
going to get that with exploring Paris
just you know this the map may be better
the story maybe whatever may be changed
but if the same sort of structural
underpinnings are there aren't you
seeing that more clearly now that you've
repeated that about the department a
different blood I mean I think it's I
think it's both I mean part of it is
just it's it's series fatigue there's
yes as Assassin's Creed every year or
two Assassin's Creed every year or three
Assassin's Creed every year and a bunch
of a bunch of related things like comics
and mobile games and and and all that
stuff so I mean even me like who I
thought was like nobody could love
Assassin's Creed more than me I thought
like as a rule you know I you know
finally you know unity came out it's
just like I didn't care and I and as
much as I loved for that they're just
some of the magic is lost yeah you do it
too much and after a while I just I'm
not really into this one more what I
like to go for that what I liked about
foreign I don't take it necessarily
appeals to me but what I liked about
four is that they tried to change it and
they try to stop it being this
very much a rigid you were going here
you were doing this like four tried to
give you the idea of all right just go
ahead and find your own phone like there
is the main quest stuff going on but
there is actually quite a lot of just
random stuff you can go do if you want
to do a plus it had sailing I mean
Assassin's Creed 3 have the sailing but
the in for they really made that a huge
thing it was sort of it there's more or
less sort of a just a side thing that
you didn't Assassin's Creed 3 and assess
Creed for it was it was front and center
because it had bigger spaces because it
took time to breathe um I think that's
what made it interesting and and you
know when you get back to like what what
unity did for example and it's just like
cramming all the you know all the icons
together and the same thing with far cry
and the crew and things yet that and and
that's the other thing is of course when
you apply that formula cross all the
watchdog's as well yeah and watch dogs
as well like you start you you get wise
to it the tricks don't work is yes
anywhere and you missed that red dead
kind of feeling where it there was room
to breathe and there was room to go out
and find something interesting which one
of the things I love about the witcher
by the way I almost wish I had been here
for that because you know that's that's
the kind of thing i like is okay leave
me two things yeah but don't show me
everything don't tip your hand because
then all it does is make me feel like
all this represents to you is not crew
you know creativity or imagination or
mystery it just represents boxes you
check at a certain distribution level
and it's hard to get lost in a world
it's hard to get like you know
distracted by something in a game world
and run off in that way when you've
already got like this checklist of 20
things you need to do already like it's
almost like a burden that that stays
really oh I've got so much like I think
that perhaps like I kind of fold myself
for this little bit but with AC for the
reason why I stopped playing it at a
certain point was like mad I'm never
gonna finish this like there's so much
stuff here and I just went alright I
know my chopping down yeah yeah so so
and that's that's really I mean I'm glad
they branched out I mean it does seem
like because there's gonna be there
gonna be two more of these things
there's going to be one in India and one
in Russia these chronicles game yeah and
and I'm super looking forward to what
they do in part because it was just so
beautiful like I want to be in these
places but then when you don't do
anything with these places when the
stories just kind of blah when the
gameplay is just kind of blah you know I
so you know
of the things I love about assassins
creed is the free running and when
that's sort of taken away there's a
there's a little bit of that edge lost I
thing